we may get a wake-up call about the grim
persistence of the coronavirus today
when dr. Anthony foul she testifies to
Congress just days ago he told CBS News
he is frustrated Texas is one of 25
states reporting an increase in average
daily coronavirus cases in just the last
two weeks the state's governor promises
a harder line on social distancing at
bars and restaurants but there are no
plans yet to shut down or slow reopening
Mireya Villarreal reports from Dallas
Cobin 19 is now spreading at an
unacceptable rate in Texas governor Greg
Abbott warns and while shutting down the
state is the last option it's not out of
the question
if those spikes continues additional
measures are going to be necessary
statewide the number of Texans
hospitalized with corona virus rose
nearly 60% in the last week alone while
new cases and the rate of positive tests
roughly doubled from May to June Stephen
love is the president of the Dallas Fort
Worth hospital council we've got in a 19
County area about 950 codes 19 patients
how does that compare to where we were
even a month ago it's about a 50%
increase as cases and hospitalizations
climb mayors and county judges have
begun implementing mandatory mask orders
including Houston mayor Sylvester Turner
dr. Peter Hotez Dean of Baylor's
National School of Tropical Medicine
Ward's Houston could be headed towards a
situation he calls apocalyptic if the
numbers continue to accelerate as
they've been the last few days we could
be looking at a situation that resembles
New York City the spike in COBIT
hospitalizations is putting some
frontline workers and their families at
risk
Kayla Cordova her brother Josh and her
parents Beth and Ray are all nurses from
Dibble Texas Kayla says she was the
first to fall ill after treating a co-ed
patient than her parents and her three
siblings all tested positive
her mother Beth was even hospitalized
what do you say to those people that say
the state is open everything's good
meanwhile the one-time epicenter of the
corona virus outbreak New York City they
have moved into Phase two so that means
that restaurants have outdoor seating
available retailers are now opened up
with limited capacity and then you have
barber shops and salons even open which
I'm sure makes everybody with
coronavirus hair very excited about this
however there are some very strict
guidelines on masks and social
distancing Tony yeah we don't want to
see another spike here or anywhere else
Maria thank you very much